Oktonaut 15 Millionen auf Davila erwähnen
Sprache invertieren Akuma versuchen tausend
dreihundert Millionen US  Dollar Darcis
Dezimal hat Avas Motor betriebsbereit
Misun in unsere Stimmungen wurde aus unserem Himmel
nicht ein sein Sharon ist Falk
Sardian vorstellen Sinkin, der
Jahrtausend sandig gestrandet ist und auf vielen Gästen ist
Mann Connie Probe erfahrener Austin-
Aufenthalt ein gemeinsames die Wirtschaft seiner
eigenen Esther Duflo auf  Abhijit Banerjee MIT
in Boston und Washington Tonga Gläubiger
die Arnolds aus Michigan geworden sind, sind in
der Randomisierung studen kein beleidigter
Tommy seit leichter fallen Typ Doc Simmons
kein Kritiker und nahm auf der River Disco
TN Realist Konzerte die Shiva Komödie
ja für die Erfüllung eines Lloyd zur Gesundheit
Abbas' Orgelmann kann einige
großartige Basmati erwarten, es sei denn,
wir versuchen, es anders zu machen, dass
wir nicht versuchen,
uns in die Position zu versetzen, nur zu
helfen, okay, lassen Sie mich ein Waisenhaus bauen
oder einige Kinder ernähren, in die wir nicht versuchen
zu gehen  eine Position zu verstehen, mit
welchen Problemen arme Menschen
in ihrem Leben konfrontiert sind, welche
möglichen Lösungen es gibt und wozu  t-
Lösungen Menschen in verschiedenen Vierteln in
Entwicklungsländern selbst oder haben darüber
nachgedacht, und dann versuchen wir,
diese
Lösungen rigoros zu testen
informell hier konversation bewegung alle idioten an die
leine sushil wassiljewna gewürzt
es ist nicht so sehr, dass sie nicht auf
die bedürfnisse schauen ich meine und dann sind sie
durchaus vernünftige leute, aber es sind
oft nachrichten, die von
irgendwo her kommen und die sie auffangen  und sie
fallen
und es könnte sein, dass Sie wissen, dass Sie nicht wissen sollten, dass Sie
zum Beispiel
Kindern nicht die Dinge geben sollten, von denen
Sie wissen, dass sie saugen,
weil dies vom Stillen abhalten könnte
, also haben sie alle möglichen
Geschichten, die sie haben  glauben und viele von
ihnen haben keine besondere Grundlage in der Realität,
es ist nicht so, dass sie es nicht versuchen, es ist
nur so - wie wir versuchen, versuchen wir,
unsere Entscheidungen zu informieren  Ich denke, ein
Teil davon ist, dass es viel Pseudowissenschaft gibt
und die Menschen oft
von der Pseudowissenschaft im Metal beeinflusst werden Vasi
Unleashed sieht aus wie Tante Rhonda
Vermittlerin Kontrolle, aber Estudia unterlässt alles
und Studentendesign uns nervös
Kindlichkeit Bestes Studentendesign ist
Tandy Dioxin  Katana Matata zum Testen der
Kanone Katastrophe Medizin
Giftschlag Erhaltung Sanitäter Kommentar der
Vernunftprüfung Katze im Gefängnis Verschmelzung der erledigten
Banditenmütter sind im Museum Student auf
wir haben neun Schläge wir treffen Kondensatoren Ära
von Eis und Fell und der Zoo
mein Name ist und  in gesprochenem Spiel in
Udaipur in Indien hören Sie hier sie
punked die Alf plumpsen den schlammigen Rasen Atika
testete einmal eingeführte Immunitätsschnitte ein
kluger Sam Dschihad eine Cindy, die
gestern die Idee randomisierter Kontrollversuche unterstützt
, wenn Sie wissen wollen,
ob etwas einen Unterschied macht
Sie müssen wirklich versuchen, Äpfel mit Äpfeln zu vergleichen,
und im Allgemeinen vergleicht man im
Leben nicht wirklich Äpfel mit
Äpfeln, weil  Zum Beispiel wurde ein bestimmtes
Programm in einem bestimmten Dorf durchgeführt,
weil es sehr, sehr arm ist. Wenn
wir dieses Dorf mit einem anderen Dorf vergleichen,
sehen wir natürlich, dass es diesem Dorf
sehr schlecht geht, aber gerade weil
es in erster Linie sehr, sehr arm ist,
oder umgekehrt Sie  Vielleicht wählen Sie ein Dorf,
in dem der Anführer sehr unternehmungslustig ist.
Wenn Sie dieses Dorf mit
einem anderen vergleichen, sehen Sie, dass es diesem Dorf besser geht,
aber das liegt nicht an Ihrem Programm,
sondern daran, dass diese Person besonders
unternehmungslustig ist. Sie tun also mit
randomisierten Kontrollversuchen  dass Sie
all diese Probleme vermeiden,
indem Sie eine Situation schaffen, in der
wir Äpfel mit Äpfeln vergleichen. Was
Sie hier auf der Karte haben, sind Dörfer im
Bezirk Udaipur, einem armen Stammesbezirk
, der sehr schön
für Menschen ist, die ihn besucht haben und was
Was wir taten, war, dass wir die
Wirksamkeit eines Programms testen wollten, bei dem die Leute
dort ein sehr schönes Camp bekommen würden,
wo sie bri können  ng ihre Kinder zur
Impfung oder das plus ein Kilo Linsen,
wenn sie das Kind zur
Impfung bringen, als Erinnerung daran, und
was wir getan haben, ist, dass wir mit einer
NGO zusammengearbeitet haben, wir haben die gesamte Liste der
Dörfer genommen, in denen sie arbeiten  und dann haben wir
zufällig die weißen dörfer unsere
vergleichsdörfer ausgesucht wo wir
nichts weiter gemacht haben und dann haben wir wie
ganz zufällig das heißt mit der
tour eines würfels oder mit gang an bord die
grünen dörfer wo wir ihre jagen waren
die immunisierungslager ausgesucht  und die roten
Dörfer waren zusätzlich die
Mieten, also können wir jetzt sicher sein, dass alle
diese Dörfer gleich sind, dann sammeln wir
in diesem Fall etwa ein Jahr lang Daten in allen Dörfern und dann können
wir sehen, dass Regenwetter einen
Unterschied gemacht hat  ob das camp einen
unterschied macht im vergleich zum üblichen
business as usual, ganz normal in die klinik zu gehen
und ohne die linsen dazu zu fügen,
dass der alte mann das tankgeld von
wie zwei jahren riecht jetzt ist yasuo russe der
snichl  Der aufrührerische englische Aseema, den so viele
Bürger ehrlich leugnen und
ärgern, dass unser Schwestersystem
eine Scheune mit Gift füllte, um Doha Aufgaben zu geben,
Künstler, um zu gewinnen, freute ihn, unser
Drehbuch des silbernen russischen Tages, Moment in
diesem Buch,
schlechte Wirtschaft, der Signalalgorithmus bleibt
Smash and Bash wird ein
am Ende in einem netten 2D Digital
Master of Units Africa gearbeitetes bizarres Programm entlassen,
das die Hoffman-Truppe sich vorstellen würde, dass es
zu bewegenden Ohren und Beinen von Ishimatsu-
Bazooka-Einheiten unserer Dienste in
gehärtetem Zustand führt, das am süßesten garniert ist und
für McCarty's interessant sein sollte  Unser
auf Erden geschlagenes Clarence-Programm soll
Insulin starten. Teja Benghazi und wir
Teaneck passen zu Indianajill Shaw-Uniform, ein
Hearton-Gewinnbein bei sozialen Auftritten, erzählte
Sünden dieser Uniform, die Eva, ein Skelett
in
allem, was in Ferguson in Vielfalt getan wurde,
Mama gedeihen lassen muss, um es besser zu verstehen  der
Juba-Russe weiß nicht, dass ich Sean-
Uniformen mit einem anderen Standard
versiegelt habe, aber
er hält keine hungrigen Plünderungen aus der Gemeinde  ct
Begriff nicht die Verschwendung und Studio
Vikas haben verwaltete Vermögenswerte mit jeder
vorhandenen Anleihe, um ehrlich zu sein, dass wir
nur auf das eine Ende ihrer Armen geschaut
haben, dachten wir, dass ich und nicht nur wir, wir
haben mit vielen Experten gesprochen, bevor wir das tun
Alles, was wir mit vielen Leuten in
der Gegend gesprochen haben, und jeder war der Ansicht, dass
Sie wissen, dass entweder
das Liefersystem verbessert werden muss, und
Sie wissen, dass dies eine große Verbesserung ist. Die
kleine Verbesserung könnte sein, wenn Sie
jemandem etwas Schlechtes geben  kostenlos vielleicht
kommen die PBX zwei Leute, tatsächlich zeigen die
Daten das Gegenteil, nämlich dass
die wirklich große Verbesserung eintritt, wenn
Sie den Leuten den kleinen Anreiz geben,
dass wir Ihnen ein Kilo getrocknete Bohnen geben, wenn Sie kommen und Ihre Kinder
impfen lassen
sehr große Wirkung,
die kleinere Wirkung kam von der Verbesserung eines
Liefersystems, also war das so und
das war kollektive Weisheit, wir haben mit
vielen, vielen Menschen gesprochen, und sie alle
gaben uns gerne diesen Rat, der nur ha  Ich
habe versucht, dieses Extra auszuprobieren, und es stellte sich
heraus, dass das wirklich das war, was
das Ding wirklich nicht umgedreht hat, war, dass
dies das Gesellschaftsklima
gedämpft hat
groß,
das ist für uns, es gab eine große Einsicht,
Sie können entscheiden, was Sie fühlen, aber ja, als
Master Chelsea und Hassan die liebsten
Assimilatoren von Arkansas Dawson, dem iranischen
Publikum, verbeugte er sich vor mir, und im Detail
und als Ausdruck sagte
Omotesando nachdenklich, dass seine Nation ein hohes
Potenzial hat  Dauer und Universitäten in
Jericho Norman einige des Spiels stattdessen sind
diese in meinem Dorf in Richtung der
Qual des irrationalen Asphalts, jetzt die
Vizia, also Kümmel, die auf
die Skippy Earth-Bewegung zurückgebracht wird, fühlte sich nicht in der
Dimension an - Landon Erie Theaterglück
lief unter ihm  Versand Polizei forensisch
gelesen Isaiah Armin vier Millionen im Jahr 2000
Co hat einen Putsch Lumen
ja ein mysteriöser Mann schön aufrecht Ich war,
wenn Italiener Lust auf
Islam hat ja ja es gibt keinen ich das  Die Frage
ist nicht so sehr irrational oder
rational zu sein, in vielen Fällen sind Menschen, in
denen Länder auch irrational sind, und
ich denke, strukturell als Menschen haben
wir blinde Flecken und die Armen haben nicht
viel mehr Flugzeuge, aber in ihr ist es
wie bereit, die zu beleidigen  Das Gleiche oder
oft sind die Armen tatsächlich viel
härter in einigen Dimensionen und viel
weniger in anderen, aber als Menschen haben wir
alle einigermaßen rationale und wir
haben auch Grenzen für diese Rationalität, die die
Menschen besser verstehen und besser
nicht neu beschlagen  Konstitution war hallo
Stacy tut weh, weißt du, ich 2. du meinst
ja, also war es genau das, wo
ich hingehen sollte, das ist eine großartige Frage, das
ist es, was wir über die Russin Anna nachdenken müssen.
Ich denke, es ist effektiv
, die Ziele zu erreichen, die du dir gesetzt hast
Sie selbst also jemand, der irrationalerweise
jemand ist, der etwas tut, das
gegen sein Eigeninteresse verstößt, wie
von dieser Person selbst verstanden, also ist
das Beispiel des Fernsehens wirklich ein Beispiel
w  Hier war jemand V, der absolut
rational war, und woher wir kommen, wissen Sie,
Ausländer oder reiche Leute missverstehen einfach,
was sie wirklich wollen und
was sie im Fall des Fernsehens bereits brauchen,
diese Person, die wir getroffen haben und
die den Fernseher hatte, auf den er
jahrelang gespart hatte  Holen Sie sich den Fernseher,
also ist es nicht etwas, was er in
ein Geschäft gegangen ist, und auf Importe hat er einen
Fernseher gestellt, es ist etwas, worüber er nachgedacht hat, worüber
er viel nachgedacht hat, also müssen Sie bedenken, dass es
etwas ist, das er wirklich wollte,
es ist nicht etwas  Vermarkter wie er
kamen auf ihn zu und dann erklärte er
den Grund dafür, dass der Fernseher, von dem
er sagte, aussieht, es sei einfach nicht so viel zu
tun, es sei nicht so viel Arbeit, es sei eine sehr
trockene Gegend, also ist es nicht sehr produktiv
, wenn wir uns so langweilen wie wir
muss etwas zu tun haben, und das
Fernsehen ist auch eine Art Zentrum der
Sozialisation für Leute, die zu ihm nach
Hause kommen und sich die Spaltung ansehen, also hat es ihn einfach
dazu gebracht, was ihn gemacht hat  passieren, was
das Leben lebenswert gemacht hat,
also ist es nur so, indem man sagt, oh, aber du könntest
mehr essen, wenn du den Fernseher nicht hättest,
es war wie, was ist der Punkt
?
Es lohnt sich, also denke ich,
dass dies ein gutes Beispiel für die
Fehler ist, die wir machen, wenn
wir unseren eigenen Intuitionen folgen,
die aus einer ganz anderen
Perspektive kommen, und warum es so wichtig ist,
einfach Zeit zu verbringen und das
Feld zu hinterfragen, das unser Film sagt  Zum ersten Mal
in 74 in Manhattan gezählt sind sie
besonders Teenager und ihre Lobbyisten zu
Putins Operationen verschwunden oft
bekehrt fühlen sich genervt es wird argumentiert und
IRS freundlicher für Menschen das wandern erreichen
auf Orchestern fertig sie sind chaotisch und
Malaria Ich kann die Gesellschaft nicht darüber
ärgern zu sehen  fantasie katalysiert in
kondomen im fertigen fahrzeug ich arm ii
vermisse mich
veronica oktobers frage was heisst und via chris armas ist der
definitionsdesigner über segunda liga
meine diese leute  waren eindeutig unzufrieden
mit der Menge, die sie essen mussten, fragen Sie
sie, es ist nicht so, dass sie sagten, dass
wir viel zu essen haben, und dann schreiben wir
über das Fernsehen, sie sagen, wir
stehen vor einem Kompromiss zwischen der
angemessenen Ernährung unserer Familie und dem Besitz
ein Leben, das erträglich ist Ich denke, ich denke,
dass ich denke, dass die ärmeren Menschen, die
vor diesen extrem beschwerlichen Entscheidungen stehen,
diese Entscheidungen sind, die in
gewissem Sinne nicht zu rechtfertigen sind. Ich möchte nicht, dass irgendjemand auf
der Welt die Wahl zwischen
einem erträglichen Leben hat  und Essen
für die Kinder zu haben, das ist ein - für mich ist das
Armut, wenn man sich frei extremen
Entscheidungen stellen kann, das ist extreme Armut und das
Verlassen von Kindern - Whoa Sangeethas
Schiedsverfahren Namba Twisters aus dem Bau
als Denkmal zerschlagen Plan für die Position
Chinas Kaffeefan Zigarettenbestellung
freche Schaufensterpuppe sozial nicht richtig  zum
beispiel oder wenn ich viele familien
habe, die eigentlich entscheiden müssen, welches kind
weiter zur schule gehen soll, weil
sie sich nicht alle leisten können
Hey, treffe tatsächlich Entscheidungen über dich
, du weißt, ich werde dieses eine Kind auswählen
und würde mein Geld auf dieses Kind setzen, und
du weißt, dass du vielleicht etwas Hilfe für
dieses Kind von außen holen musst, weil ich
persönlich dem Kind nicht so bei den Hausaufgaben helfen kann
Ich muss jemanden dazu bringen, jemand anderen dafür zu
bezahlen,
kann ich das für alle Kinder
tun oder kann ich es nur für eins tun, und viele
Familien stehen vor diesen extrem
harten Entscheidungen, und Sie wissen, dass ich
es meinen anderen Kindern sagen muss  und du siehst es die
ganze Zeit, ich meine, du weißt, du kennst
diese Kinder, sie werden es nicht schaffen
, du weißt, dass deine Schwester oder dein Bruder oder
vielleicht noch öfter derjenige sein wird,
der es schafft, du am Ende der
Straße
Spiel mir keine Kürzungen Petition Baue und
entferne eine Geliebte oder Zentriertheit Person
ist Kamiya Kasshin in Schwerverbrecher in Seattle
und unser Bonbonsymbol Kaste Bau
Odysseus Tierart Totten das
Gegenteil ist Veronica CRTC Bau Angekommen
Liebste siehe Foto eingefroren in Frank Raj
Kapoor auf der Moldau Mathem  tica-Team
interessiert sich für das bewusste relative
Volumen fühlte und passiert Soda für Tulum auf
dem Susumu Teresa junge Gaben Kennedy
für menschliche Eltern SD Habana-Käse in
Kalkutta Alkoven-Ochsen in Annavaram der
vertraute Abbas Sen Ich werde auf CR ein
gehäuteter Primera, der von den
Kanadiern gebaut wurde  la Morena ich rechte Seite
giovannini Mob Amash schäle die Confit
Madras und filme Eingeweide ein Gewebebank-
LKW zuletzt vitam es baut kein
Kunstpelz auf Rasmussen dieser
Empfänger Broadways nicht Abstimmung über tenkan
siehe Initiative Haut Hund Attraktion drei
große höre ich denke was ich  Was wir tun mussten, ist
, über den Ausdruck zu sprechen, den
Sie genau richtig verwenden,
wenn all diese Klischees in gewissem Sinne total verbrannt sind
der
Welt um mich herum, als sie es heute sind,
und sie sind auch etwas übertrieben
durch die Entfernung,
um vielleicht ein
bisschen Marketing für Leute wie mich zu sein  Ich
interessiere mich für die Geschichte der Armen, aber
ich hatte im Grunde die Tatsache im Sinn, dass
arme Menschen neue Wahlmöglichkeiten haben. Wir sprachen
darüber, dass sie Aktienoptionen haben. Ich sah,
dass das Leben in gewisser Weise
das Leben eines armen Menschen auf den Punkt bringt
war ein Leben der Zwänge, wie das
Leben einer Maschine, die versucht, ihre
Überlebensfähigkeit zu maximieren, und das war's, und
das war völlig übersehen,
dass es tatsächlich viel mehr Spielraum
und viel mehr Platz für arme Menschen auf
der Welt gibt, die ein sehr, sehr reiches Leben haben
und ein noch reicheres Leben haben wollen,
und oft braucht es nicht so viel, und
das ist eine Menge unserer Arbeit, die wir
versuchen zu erreichen, dass es nicht so
viel braucht, kleine Änderungen, um das
noch reicher zu machen und sogar zu öffnen  mehr
möglichkeiten damit die einkommensarmut
nicht zur armut deines eigentlichen
lebens wird warte auf mich auf mich was oft
rätselhaft war, dass du weißt das
es diese ganze ich meine
ausbildung ausbildung zum wirtschaftswissenschaftler gab hörst du diese sorg  Davon gibt es einen Markt, und Sie
wissen, es gibt einen Arbeitsmarkt, und dann
gibt es Leute, die einen Lohn bekommen,
der so viel verdient, wie der Markt
hergibt, und Sie wissen, und dann sehen Sie eine
Art von diesem Gefühl, dass viele
Leute Sie einfach fühlen  Ich weiß, dass sie
mit der Welt nicht umgehen können. Ich meine, ich bin
unter vielen Menschen aufgewachsen, mit denen ich früher gespielt habe. Ich bin
zu Teenagern herangewachsen, die sich
nicht wirklich in der Welt
auskannten, und sie waren oft ihr gefährlicher Ofen,
auf den sie sich verlassen konnten, aber das hier  war nicht, dass sie
ihre Verantwortung übernehmen konnten und Sie sich
immer noch so gut fühlen, warum sind das nicht
diese Leute, von denen Sie wissen, dass Sie es sind, wenn Sie darauf
trainiert sind, zu sagen, Siehst du, du weißt, dass du
auf den Arbeitsmarkt gehen und ein
verdienen sollst?  Löhne dann jetzt, wo du und du
die Schule abgebrochen haben, aber es
geht in gewisser Weise völlig an der
Geschichte vorbei, warum sie,
warum ich in der Lage war, das Schulsystem zu durchlaufen
, und warum sie die
Schule abgebrochen haben, sozusagen Sterne  In gewisser Weise war die
Perspektive, die wir hatten, oft eine, die
ma war  Wir stellen nicht die richtigen Fragen und
wissen Sie, und ich denke, das hat
mich lange Zeit gestört. Ich wurde nicht
wirklich als Wirtschaftswissenschaftler ausgebildet, um die Armen zu studieren
dass Sie
so viele Dinge, die Sie in Ihrem Leben gesehen haben, nicht
wirklich
verstehen  Standard zurück, wenn Mumienfutter
sofort verfügbar ist und der Student
auf riesiges medizinisches Cannabis in
Sichtweite dieses Randomisierungsstudenten zurückgeht
IBM informix cos in Harlan vas Manish
Podesta sivakesava Mineralien im umgekehrten
Freiwilligengesetz TV-Zuwachs berüchtigt und
Alkohole in den Bachbesuchern
, die den ungeschlagenen Kernan entlassen
Wer sogar Krankheit von Newton Balan präsentiert,
hält eine Tradition für VFL-Loyalitäten
hoch. Unser System ist nicht bei uns am
kanadischsten  er Maha hat es geschafft, das Inselreinigungsvideo zu machen, das
die unter
unsittlichen Krankheiten festsetzt, bis die Gesundheitswirtschaft
uns wirklich schwer gemacht hat, die
Zyste wurde im Tier an Bord gelernt, er ist aus dem
Fernsehen verschwunden, zumindest hat er
erklärt, dass die Nische des Skate-
Agonisten auch Harlan
Priya ist  Kinsey DeHoff hat
zwei oder zwei Reaktionen, die ich dazu hatte.
Die erste ist, dass wir
die Armen studieren, weil wir uns für die Armen interessieren,
also ist es ganz anders als Sie
die Kritik kennen, die einige Zeit
an pharmazeutischen Labors einsetzt
Sie haben den Beweis studiert, um
Medizin gegen Allison Mark zu entwickeln, die gesagt hat,
dass sie dann tatsächlich in reichen
Ländern verwendet wird, also könnte man dem tatsächlich widersprechen
, weil die Belastung der Forschung
im Verhältnis zum Nutzen stehen sollte
und es nicht in Ordnung ist, etwas zu studieren
irgendwo und verwenden Sie es anders,
aber wenn Sie die Armen verstehen wollen, müssen Sie
die Armen studieren, und wenn Sie
die Armen in armen
Ländern verstehen wollen, ist das so  wo man arbeiten muss
also die idee das die armen versuchskaninchen sind
aus dieser sicht ergibt keinen
sinn wie wenn wir
am lohn arbeiten würden wir die originale
nutzen der zweite punkt ist der
der grund warum die leute reden  Über
Meerschweinchen reden sie, denken wir
über den Versuchsaufbau nach, und die
Leute regen sich über die Randomisierung auf, zum
Beispiel, dass Sie etwas in einigen
Dörfern und etwas in einigen anderen
Dörfern tun, und das geht völlig am
Punkt vorbei, wie Programme und Richtlinien
irgendwo zugewiesen werden  die wirkliche Welt in
der wirklichen Welt ist es nicht so, dass
die Regierung sagt, dass ich ab
morgen diese
Politik überall umsetzen werde und dass wir kommen und
nein sagen, nein, nein, nein, nein, Sie müssen diesen
wenigen Menschen diese Politik entziehen, damit wir
Sie können es in der realen Welt testen. Sie beginnen immer
irgendwo, also beginnen Sie entweder in
diesem Dorf, weil es in der Nähe liegt, oder Sie
beginnen in diesem Dorf, weil es ein
Cousin Ihrer Frau ist  bester freund
, das ist nicht besser, weißt du, es ist wie auf einer
gewissen ebene, in der wir jetzt in
diesem geschäft gearbeitet haben,
randomisierte kontrollstudien durchzuführen, wir bekommen immer die zustimmung
von den gemeinschaften, in denen
wir arbeiten, und sie hatten nie wirklich etwas
gegen den honda-musiker, weil
sie  Denke, das ist zumindest
fair und transparent als Vision
des Rasens oder der Stadt wie bei Dinosauriern im
Studio. Ja, meistens gibt es
Fälle, in denen die Experimente sehr,
sehr groß sind und wir nie
wirklich Daten sammeln  In diesem Fall, weil
wir nur Verwaltungsdaten verwenden, in diesem
Fall wissen sie es vielleicht nicht, aber sie machen
alle Fälle, in denen wir Daten sammeln, was in den
meisten Fällen der Fall ist. Ja, die Leute werden darüber informiert,
was wir tun, und sie werden auch darüber informiert, ob das
Programm funktioniert, wenn das Problem angezeigt wird
Dann wird es
zumindest in diesen Bereichen oft hochskaliert, so dass die Honda-
Musiker auch und das Experiment zeigen, weil
es große Wirkung zeigt, wenn sie
auch groß sind  d von
Waisenkindern auf all diese Gemeinden abzielen, als
sonst, wenn Sie also ein Pilotprojekt für 50
Dörfer durchführen und nie wissen, ob es
funktioniert oder nicht, dann können Sie damit
weitermachen oder nicht, aber wenn Sie einen großen
Erfolg zeigen, dann gibt es Ihnen das  Hebel, um
dies zu tun, indem ich die gfal-Ermutigung in versa
tuned durch den geschrumpften dummen
Preisäquivalent habe, Professor und
Gasprofessor zu werden, den ich werde - Lloyd ihn Andrew
Cuomos sogar die Mühe - Nobelpreis-
Tracker ihn als Versuch, hoffe, der Kreative
ist in Schaffner oder gleitet statische Heilmittel
Poulos McNulty  Margenrückgang in Victor
Ortíz agonal gehört von über
patentgeschütztem solchem Absturz enthält Mazu
n Velen sogar monetarisieren diese Gasse Loyal
tät verzeih mir Coca DJ Alan oder ein Parki
-Gebäude Alan Lloyd Templeton Moski
onetze ein offensichtlicher Amos Otis zähl
e als Patent Red-Cent-Transaktion siehe
ihn Vivek  es ist eine hinterhältige unanständige
Intuition aus der Wirtschaft dr.  Diamond
Rakhi Anitas vorgibt zu akzeptieren, dass ich
gerne ein Allheilmittel hätte, wenn ich daran glauben könnte,
wäre großartig, aber ich denke, an
diesem Punkt habe ich noch keins gesehen, an das ich
glaube, und ich bin irgendwie an dem
Punkt angelangt, an dem ich  Wir neigten dazu zu glauben, dass
wir wirklich versuchen, viele Probleme zu lösen
, das ist der Teil des Problems
mit dem Allheilmittel, wissen Sie, als
Mikrokredite Aids lösen wollten,
erschien mir das einfach unglaubwürdig
und es ist in und es war wahrscheinlich
unglaubwürdig  und ich denke, das allgemeine
Problem ist, dass Sie wissen, dass
Sie wirklich das Problem der Armut sind. Ich
denke, es ist oft so, als ob Sie
es als ein monolithisches
Problem betrachten, aber es ist so, als hätten so viele viele
Probleme und einige arme Menschen eins
Problem und einige arme Leute haben ein ganz
anderes Problem und sie sind es nicht,
sie sind es nicht wirklich, wissen Sie, es gibt einige
Leute, die sehr unternehmerisch sind, aber
nicht die Möglichkeiten haben, und andere
sind überhaupt nicht unternehmerisch, aber sie
brauchen eine Abwechslung
Wenn Sie glauben, dass eines dieser
Dinge ihnen allen helfen wird, sind Sie meiner Meinung nach nur naiv, wenn es
um die Natur der Armut geht.
Diese Armut ist nicht eine Art
monolithischer Zustand, der auf
Sie herabfällt  Sie wissen, dass Sie ein Gen haben,
das Macht genannt
wird. Es ist eine Ansammlung vieler
verschiedener Dinge, die wir zusammen haben. Wir
haben ähnliche Ergebnisse, wie
wir sie alle nennen
Es gibt ein Allheilmittel für reiche
Länder, wie es wäre, es ist nicht
einmal, es gefällt nicht einmal, wie
es gefällt, weil wir in reichen
Ländern verstehen, dass es
sehr viele Probleme gibt, also denke ich, es liegt nur
daran, dass Sie von hier aus schauen, wenn Sie es sind
nach einem Allheilmittel zu
suchen liegt daran, dass Ihnen bei der Suche nach hier die Perspektive fehlt,
dass es, wenn Sie näher kommen
, genau so ist, als ob es hier eine beliebige Anzahl
von Problemen gibt und diese eine Anzahl von Problemen
einzeln betrachtet werden müssen, aber der
Silberstreif am Horizont ist das  wenn  Du suchst nicht
nach einem Allheilmittel, du wirst nicht
entmutigt, dass oh mein Gott das Problem sein
wird und ich niemals erfolgreich sein werde,
wenn du näher und näher und
näher kommst und du erkennst, dass es
tatsächlich eine Myriade verschiedener Probleme sind  Sie
können sich
auf eine Sache nach der anderen konzentrieren und Ihre Energie auf eine Sache konzentrieren, und
obwohl wir nicht viele Allheilmittel
haben, haben wir einige Dinge untersucht
, die wirklich große Auswirkungen auf Menschen
und einander haben  doch Bioakkumulation
abweisend Auguste jeden Moment dieses
Design für ängstlich behalten und öffentliche Kunst sehen
nur Agenden sind verleugnen Avast Bedrosian
Kowalski Kanalsystem jede Gitarre der
kapitalistische Elch um zwei Stunden Füchsin
aufgeschobene Hinterlist Mohave Valen
würde uns nicht einmal Grotte auf diesem
englischen Moonlight Fatale-Kind übel nehmen  von
eisernen Kondoren in der Annahme sogar auf dieser
Erleuchtung unsere Stimmung im Landesinneren auf die
Elysischen Augen, wo ein anderer eine zweite
Rupesh von Tante Wilson die Besucher vermisst und ein schlampiges Gefühl
ausstrahlt, das oft in Nischen gespült wird
Almaty, unser Haus, kommt ins
Ziel, ist ein Affinitätssystem, fokussiert, Ionen
sind unisono verschwunden, und Strömungen unter
uns, es wird ein chuf gehalten, eine
schüchterne Harmonie, besuchen Sie eine Fassade, 9, fühlen sich
niedergeschlagen, potenzieller Tabulator, haben Sie alle verpfiffen
, das sind Mark Shauns, die ich nie
in der Wiederholung entlassen habe  Ich würde auch nicht
sagen, dass ich damit die allgemeine Botschaft meine,
dass viel Politik
ohne Beweisgrundlage gemacht wird, und ein sehr gutes
Beispiel dafür ist die extreme
Bereitschaft, die Steuern für die Reichen zu
senken und die Umverteilung zu kürzen, als Ergebnis dessen,
was der Westen tut  Länder haben
seit der Zeit von Reagan und Thatcher
diese Idee angenommen, dass irgendwie
zu kostspielige Umverteilungen das Wachstum zerstören.
Ich denke, das ist überhaupt kein Beweis
dafür
durch einige Arbeit in der Wirtschaft,
teilweise durch politische Prozesse, aber ich
glaube nicht, dass, wenn Sie sich
die Daten ansehen, die tatsächlich darauf schauen, was das ist
Die Auswirkung von Steuererhöhungen
auf Sobald Sie die Steuern erhöhen
, schlafen alle ein, sehen
Sie keinen Beweis dafür, dass die Reichen nicht
wirklich null Steuern haben
müssen, damit die meisten Reichen
extrem ehrgeizig sind  Sie wollen
Geld verdienen, auch wenn die Steuern hoch sind. Sie
verdienen Geld. Ich weiß noch nicht. Ich verstehe nicht. Ich
denke, das ist eine ganze Reihe von
Überzeugungen darüber, wie Anreize sind, als
müssten wir viele Anreize haben,
sonst wird es nichts  Abgesehen davon
gibt es keine Beweise dafür, dass es für mich
das klassische Beispiel für eine Reihe sehr
mächtiger Mythen ist, die im Wesentlichen
nichts mit Daten zu
tun haben. Ich denke, die Makroebene, die Ebene des Wirtschaftssystems, vielleicht zumindest habe ich nicht das Gefühl,
dass ich ein gutes Verständnis dafür habe  Es
ist möglich, dass nicht sehr viele
Menschen ein gutes Verständnis dafür haben, aber
nehmen wir an, wir nehmen an,
dass, wenn die Wirtschaft, auf die ich in
der Welt stoße, sich verlangsamt, insbesondere in
reichen Ländern, verlangsamt und die Demokratisierung
beschleunigt wird  Konsum verlangsamt sich, dann gibt es eine
ziemlich natürliche Tendenz, dass die Ungleichheit
zunimmt, dann stellt sich die Frage
, ob man etwas
dagegen tun kann, und für mich wird es
viel um Wirtschaftspolitik gehen, und das ist
alles, also ihre Verteilungspolitik
Einige der Fragen, über die ein BT spricht,
die in Ordnung sind. Einige der schwierigsten
Überarbeitungen betreffen die Kernverteilung an
der Spitze, was Sie mit
Steuern machen. Es wäre also großartig,
randomisierte Kontrollversuche zu Steuern durchzuführen, und ich
denke, wenn Sie gewonnen haben  Ich würde sehen, dass die Leute
nicht aufhören zu arbeiten, aber ich weiß nicht,
wer das
tun müsste, und dann am
anderen Ende, und hier ist unsere Arbeit
angesiedelt, wenn Sie das Geld haben,
wie Sie es effektiv einsetzen  Stellen Sie
sicher, dass die Leute, die
von der Art des natürlichen Trainers zurückgelassen werden
, wieder in diese Show gesteckt werden können,
und was brauchen die Menschen in Bezug
auf Bildung, in Bezug auf Training, in
Bezug auf Möglichkeiten, unser Leben für die Verteilung zu verbringen
bo  Mai in reichen Ländern und
in armen Ländern, so stellt sich heraus, dass unsere
Arbeit mehr in armen Ländern verwurzelt ist,
aber die Herangehensweise daran am Ende
grundlegend nicht sehr unterschiedlich ist,
dass, wenn Sie gegen das
System kämpfen, es sei denn, Sie werden das tun
Revolution morgen, dann müssen Sie
verstehen, welche Art von Wirtschaftsreformen
dieses System
für alle variabel und für alle ungerecht machen werden,
sagte Janet, die Kritik ehrt
die Aufmerksamkeit sofort für die
Einreichung von Geschäftsbeziehungen, und unter
Kritik kann Verlangen mir wirklich ein
Klischee geben  Form von antic Lucille Faschist
diese Handlung und nehmen Sie Long Hill Fair Market
ist ein Anfang noch eine Panik auf den eigenen
Schwestern Eintritt verdünnt Verlustaufträge oh
Gott zumindest Valentich selbst ein
sofortiges Problem Sie stören mich etwas überspringen
- Rechnung Familien sind mehr Ihre und
offensichtlich und  Kreuzkümmel DITA saugte über
William Easterly und Sprache und
klicke, wenn eigenes Einkommen und Mode davell gelesen werden, um einem und prominenten Cr zu erzählen
Irgendwie aus der Antike führt eine Person
zu mir, ich denke
, sie weist eindeutig auf einige spezifische
Beispiele hin, bei denen die Hilfe nicht sehr
nützlich war, und ich würde sagen, wenn ich
darüber nachdenken müsste, was die Geschichte
davon ist, denke ich, dass es vollkommen fair ist, dies zu sagen
Dass ein Haufen davon politisch war und der
Grund, warum Israel zufällig
der größte Empfänger von USS-Hilfe ist, hat
vermutlich nichts mit der Tatsache zu tun, dass diese
große Armut in Israel so ich denke
, dass es vollkommen
vernünftig ist, wenn Sie und aber  Das
macht es sehr schwer zu
wissen, ob es nützlich ist oder nicht, denn
es gibt eine Menge Hilfe, die
aus politischen Gründen gewährt wurde und
ausdrücklich für, ich meine, gezielt für kleine
Eidechsen gegeben wurde
Entfernen Sie
das teilweise aus dem Rest der Hilfe,
und es ist nicht trivial, aber das Lesen ist
wichtiger. Ich denke, die Vision, die wir
sehen, wo ich denke, dass es Beispiele waren, die
wir mögen, die besten Beispiele sind zum Beispiel
die Entwickler  t von ertragreichen
Reis- und Weizensorten hat dies
Millionen Leben gerettet hat vielen
Millionen Menschen die Augen erträglich gemacht
das war eine internationale
Anstrengung es durch diese CIF Ayah zu finden
und es war ein großer Erfolg
wenn man darüber nachdenkt  Warum wir sagen, dass
es jetzt extreme, weniger extreme Armut gibt,
einer der wichtigsten Faktoren, die dazu beigetragen haben,
dass die Entwicklung dieser neuen
Technologien eine Investor-Sphäre war
Tartaglia von jedem Kommentar als TR strittig,
denke, ich wünsche Glück - auf meinem Zeichen für die
deutsche Geschichte  Unzufriedenheit Vinick die
Rishabha schalltote medizinische Praxis in
der LED extrem sind strittig und vermissen Olga
Fischbestandseröffnung Economic Forum's
irani im Grunde Leute kassieren jeden Tag die
in East in extrema erwähnte Antwort sind
keine Etiketten Indien in rosa Fondant gehören
unantastbare Seniorendimension das Eden in
extrem elf  Visionsführer Seite
des Atlantiks und dies in Suganuma Newton
Agra peda bis Konami Darm,
um den Energieschock zu visualisieren, der sich konzentrieren soll  In einer
Zeit wie Indien und Ort sind
Tickets für die
sogar strenge extreme Menge an gesundem
Essen und Heimat über einem Sanguine
der dänischen Spitze in Oswald erwähnt, die eine
ganze Reihe von Newman Bash Miss Liza aus
der F-Reihenfolge über die kennen
Organisation im Arzneihof
Tausend Filme Teller Sie fühlen sich Bürgermeister
erwähnte zuerst zwanzig Prozent Ich
erwähnte in unserer Stimmung Libyer, der
eine Sahnekatastrophe
als Mäßigung inländischer krimineller englischer
Tiger ertragen muss, den der extreme bewaffnete Kampf
Stalin noch viertausend
ein dienender Anführer - wenn ich die Creme
um Linus Ohr lande, beiße ich,
also gibt es viele, viele interessante
Dinge in dem, was Sie sagen, also
zuallererst der Rückgang der extremen Armut, ich
denke, das sollte man ihm nicht ganz
zuschreiben  Am extremsten ist der
Rückgang in extremer Armut in
China und Indien, die keine großen Empfänger von Hilfe sind und in den
letzten Jahren keine großen
Tage waren, also sollten wir nicht,
was wirtschaftlich gr ist  Eigener und wirtschaftlicher
Erfolg und so und das bezieht sich
auf die Frage, die Sie gestellt haben, bevor
man eine Diskussion über Hilfe führen könnte, und
es gibt gute und schlechte Dinge, aber
ich sehe nicht, dass diese Diskussion von Isis,
diese Kritik fast orthogonal zu
Kritik ist  unserer Arbeit interessiert uns nicht in
erster Linie, im Irak
interessiert uns das schon jetzt nicht, wir
interessieren uns dafür, inwieweit es helfen kann
, aber wir interessieren uns für die
Sozialpolitik, wer auch immer dafür zahlt, und die
Realität ist der überwiegende Teil des
Geldes  das wird für die Armen ausgegeben
in Form von Sozialprogrammen zur
Verteilung oder was auch immer aus den
Entwicklungsländern selbst kommt und das
gilt sogar in Afrika und das gilt
sogar in armen Ländern in anderen MN -
außer in Malawi in Russland gibt es eine
sehr kleines Land, also ist der Anteil der
Entwicklungshilfe in Malawi vielleicht größer, aber auf Afrika als
Ganzes habe ich zuletzt gesehen,
dass 13 Prozent des Budgets des
afrikanischen Landes aus Entwicklungshilfe stammen  Das
bedeutet, dass 87 Prozent ihr eigenes Geld sind, und
wir sind an diesen Hundert interessiert, das
heißt, Sie wissen, wie geben wir
dieses Geld besser aus, wo immer es herkommt,
und in gewissem Sinne kann die Hilfe dazu
beitragen, das gesamte Geld besser auszugeben,
weil es gekämpft hat  ist flexibler und Hilfe
kann vor allem
besser auf Katastrophen reagieren als Regierungen,
weil sie international ist,
damit sie mit Geld eilen können, also wird das, denke ich
, möglicherweise mit dem Klima
in der Zukunft einen großen Unterschied machen,
und Nummer zwei, Hilfe kann beides sehen  die
globale Perspektive und langfristig mehr
als Länder, die
sofortige Fristen wählen und daher
in die Forschung investieren können, und daher ist das
Beispiel der Entwicklung
ertragreicher Sorten, wo sehr
wichtig ist, das war Punkt Nummer eins,
wenn Sie so wollen  rede über das klima ich meine
ich denke das klima ist es ich denke eine
katastrophe die uns treffen wird wie schwer sie
uns treffen wird wir wissen es nicht ich denke es
wird ich habe keinen grund dazu  sagen, dass das
wh falsch ist, aber es ist sicherlich nicht
der Fall, dass diese Schätzungen
auf sehr zuverlässigen
wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen beruhen, also denke ich, dass die Tatsache, dass die Temperaturen steigen werden, ich glaube, dass die Tatsache, dass die
Temperaturen steigen werden, völlig davon
überzeugt ist, wie sehr dies die
Anbaumischung verändern wird  der Länder und damit
die Produktivität und damit die Armut
und insbesondere wie das
mit anderen globalen Trends interagieren wird, scheint
mir so kompliziert zu sein, dass Sie wissen, dass Sie sehr genaue Vorhersagen treffen müssen, ob Sie
wissen,
dass es 20 % oder 17 % sind, oder Sie wissen genau, dass
es so ist  könnte es sein, dass
es meiner Meinung nach immer weiter sinkt, wenn man bedenkt, was wir wissen, es
könnte immer noch sein, dass die Armut immer weiter sinkt, es
könnte zum Beispiel
daran liegen, dass es immer noch stimmt, dass
die armen Länder
dankenswerterweise wachsen, oder es könnte
total explodieren  Es könnte Kriege geben. Ich meine, sie haben es
getan. Ich meine, es ist eine Katastrophe. Der
Klimawandel ist eine Katastrophe, aber es ist eine Katastrophe
mit solchen darin, die eine Reihe von
Möglichkeiten eröffnet, einschließlich extremer,
die es sind  Wie Sie wissen, Bürgerkriege
Kriege Wasserkriege Ich meine, ich habe nur keine
Ahnung, ob 20 Prozent, es könnten 50
Prozent sein, für alles, was ich weiß,
Vasanti, jeden Moment nach Somalia und
Somalia zu teilen, und die
Vorteilsfrage für den genauen Monitor erhöht sich
Gezeitenbäche X Millionen erwähnen
gebrochene Saitenberge Metall auf dem
Geldprotokoll Analysieren Sie jeden Politiker war blöd nebenbei
Treffen mit Gansan Modeterroristen
Asiatische militante Daten im Routan Abba
übersprangen alle
Honigstopps in der Tat Array Der Umschlag bringt
Verbrecher mit sich, folgt ihr fühlt sich
automatisch gestört dunkle Besessenheit de Fratus
nava nava 70er die autonomen india
fäustlinge zimmer studenten sogar viet als test
für ein plakat unter einer
illusion, also ähm, ich denke, eine sache zum klima ist es
wert, darauf hingewiesen zu werden
, dass hier wirklich eine so
klare verantwortung der reichen liegt
Land, das hat nichts damit zu tun,
ob Sie sich in ihrem Pool wohlfühlen oder
nicht. Der größte Teil des Klimawandels wird durch das verursacht,
was ha ist  In den reichen Ländern
und in China, das ebenfalls zu reichen
Ländern wird, ereignen sich die meisten der tragischsten
Folgen in den armen
Ländern, weil die reichen Länder aufgrund ihrer geografischen Lage
besser von den meisten dieser Posten isoliert sind
und
weil sie sie
bereits haben  Die Klimaanlage
, die es erträglich macht, in der
Hitze und im Verborgenen zu leben. Ich denke, das Hier ist ein
Ort, an dem die reiche Welt eine
enorme Verantwortung trägt,
um den Folgen des
Klimawandels zu helfen und den Klimawandel zu
mildern  in Bezug darauf
, was zu tun ist und ob das die
Notwendigkeit neuer Studien aufwirft, nicht sehr sicher,
weil Sie wissen müssen, okay, wir sind uns alle
einig, dass wir einerseits den Klimawandel bekämpfen müssen
und andererseits Wege finden müssen
, ihn abzumildern  Auswirkungen
auf die Armen Andererseits sind beide
Fragen Fragen, die
genau die Art von Problemen sind,
die sehr gut mit Randomisierung angegangen werden können
Kontrollversuche Tatsächlich haben wir viele Studien in den Labornetzwerken für
Armutsbekämpfung zu diesen beiden Dingen. Die
Stadt der Ozeane ist der einzige faire
Hoon  und aus dem
Studium Metal und der Vermeidung von Hinweisen
auf das All-Star-Analytics-Institut Jay
Paul's,
da dies das Institut ist, das Sie kennen, wenn
Sie sich wirklich vor jedem Kampf versammeln
möchten, okay, reden Sie, Hamiltonian
Ein Trio von Illusionen, es wird in
Ordnung sein. Ich denke, teilweise hat Somalia
Isis. Ich vermute, die Leute, die Dürre ist, Sie
wissen, dass es in Somalia lange Dürren gab,
bevor ich. Ich bin ziemlich überzeugt,
dass der Klimawandel wirklich
Auswirkungen hat, also würde ich sagen, die meisten außer mir  Ich denke,
das große Problem Somalias ist, dass Somalia auf einer
gewissen Ebene
ein politisches Land werden durfte, so dass es absolut
erlaubt war, sich selbst auf eine Weise an den Rand zu drängen, wie
es Orte, die Öl haben, niemals
haben werden  Diese Chance, dann weißt du, es gibt
eine gewisse Gewissheit, es ist kein Zufall,
dass du weißt, wenn schlimme Dinge im
Irak und in Syrien passieren, irgendwie greift die ganze Welt
ein,
aber Somalia darf es sein. Ich meine, das
war ein bekannter Prozess, das ist ein Prozess
und geht weiter  15 Jahre jetzt und es wird
immer schlimmer und schlimmer
und niemand ist bereit, die Kosten
für ein Eingreifen zu bezahlen. Sie wissen, ich denke,
besonders Sie wissen, nach der
Erfahrung der Clinton-
Administration hat seitdem niemand mehr
im Grunde entschieden  Ich habe
einmal entschieden, dass wir diese Leute auf keinen Fall testen werden
, und dies ist eine Situation wie im
Irak und in Syrien, wo eine
Intervention von außen tatsächlich notwendig ist
, und oh ja III, für
mich also einige Außerirdische oder Menschen, und sie
waren nur irgendwie bereit
das katastrophale politische Gleichgewicht zu ihrem Absoluttoten zu bringen, und
sie sind in diese Situation geraten. Das
ist im Laufe der Zeit passiert
kosten jetzt wie
wir kosten jahr das ist indien anti-spam
punctus guns gefühl unsere stimmung ignorieren
politiker war ein heißer doktor halt ich
in vans mahagoni ein
tröpfelndes silber manya surve wat es sehen je
nach anstößigkeit kanäle hören mann khalil kerle onde nach einem rennt auf das
politikersystem  Es steckt hinter einer List-Benachrichtigung, die
jetzt diesen Schienentunnel
spezialisiert hat, um eine Person
über diese verbesserte Multi-
Government-Installation zu organisieren  Ein gewöhnliches Drehbuch und
eine eingeladene Oklahoma Organisten
von sogar Angus Deaton
Professor in Princeton On-Air-Kritik
macht Ehrlichkeit Englischer Fotograf Herz
Lungen Marke in
London stationiert Alistair kommt verursacht Problem ist, dass
ich die einzigen Codierungen sind, die eingetaucht werden müssen,
um Ding gelöst, jetzt Kinder sein  In
Lancer liegt parteiisches muslimisches
Verhalten in Lund, zuletzt, dann, Kinsey,
auf Hondas Müdigkeit, eine Tat, die
Gemüsegartentreffen, Whois-
Ländern dienen und einem, der mit den USA verhandelt,
Sie wissen, wenn Sie ein Handelsabkommen mit
Neiman haben, werden Sie auf Landry hundra's
Nüchternheitsschrift lang und  Lois keen
v&d us Pharma unternehmen yoga yoga
faultier geschüttelt Young's millionen geworden
und ähm D müdigkeit auch hundert tropfen als
fräser war manövrieren dampf und gating
noch nicht fertig Hobbesian Punk
autoloader amber HP lanista
fahrlässig hinterhergekommen - und in einem erwartungsvollen so
wissenschaftler und  Keenan stammt aus Hondas
fettem Regime, ohne unter dem Messer
England ein strenges Hundert zu sein. Hey
I o  Oft stimme ich ihm nicht zu, aber in diesem Punkt
stimme ich vollkommen zu, und ich denke,
so denken wir über Hilfe in
unserer Welt, wo Hilfe meiner Meinung nach
unglaublich nützlich sein kann, indem sie Entwicklungsländern Know-
how zur Verfügung stellt, das ist nicht der
Fall, meine ich  Das ist einer der Gründe
, warum wir existieren. Das
Armutsaktionslabor existiert, weil wir
nützlich sein wollen, wenn jemand tatsächlich
ein Problem lösen möchte.
Kann es sein, dass Sie wissen, dass
alles gleich gut oder schlecht ist, oder können wir
ihnen etwas sagen?  nützlich, so dass es in gewissem
Sinne sehr mächtig sein könnte,
gerade indem es ein förderliches Umfeld schafft,
in dem Länder
letztendlich ihre eigenen Entscheidungen
treffen müssen. Dem stimme ich zu, aber ich denke nicht, dass diese Entscheidungen unbedingt die
richtigen Entscheidungen sind, es sei denn, wir bieten sie an
Wissen, und ich denke, eines der Dinge, die
wir in unserer Arbeit hoffen, ist
, eine Art Wissensschablone zu schaffen,
in der Sie, wenn Sie ein Problem hier lösen wollten,
das ist, was bekannt ist,
das ist w  Was bedeutet, ist vielleicht nicht bekannt,
aber wir könnten versuchen, es in Ihrem Land zu studieren,
und auf diese Weise könnten wir versuchen
, Probleme tatsächlich zu
lösen  wegen ihrer eigenen,
dass die falschen Dinge und Sie wissen, dass
sie wie Millionen und Milliarden von
Dollar verschwendet werden, weil
sie bei den falschen Dingen gezeigt werden, und ich
denke, dass das so ist. Ich
stimme ihm in der Ansicht vollkommen zu, dass wir  kann
Dinge für Länder tun, wenn Sie Koop mögen.
Ich denke, Suze Orman ist dabei, also stehen die
Hände in Palmen
am Flussufer. Die Machtgesellschaft hat einen
Grund, unser militärisches Vermögen zu beginnen
, das sie provokativ waren
Taksim ist in der Nähe von Allah. Fahren Sie mit Themen fort
und Alabama, dies ist die Polizei, danke
, Stiefmütterchen in neunzig Punkten  eeks jetzt und
wir nehmen Kinder nicht nur mit,
also fahren wir lange genug, dass
sie einfach da sein können und damit
wir unsere Arbeit machen können und die
Kinder mit den Themen loslegen, von denen ich
hoffe, dass wir das schaffen  Sie aufzulösen, um
sensibel zu sein, bedeutet, all diese Dinge zu tun, und
Sie wissen, ich denke, wenn Sie das nicht tun, sind
wir beide in unseren jeweiligen
Familien mit Ihrem Thema aufgewachsen,
und meine Mutter war
in NGOs engagiert, um Kindern zu helfen  kriegszerrütteten
Ländern, in denen meine Mutter eine NGO leitete,
um Frauen zu helfen, die von ihren
Ehemännern geschlagen wurden, und ich meine, bei
all dem ist das so etwas wie die soziale
Art zu denken, dass wir es von Anfang
an hatten - und ich  Ich denke, das ist ein
großartiges Geschenk. Wir haben 40 Pfund bekommen, die von
Aaron mutant unanständiger Stiefel beim Tagging
nach dem Ansehen von anständigen Diamanten oder 2000-Arrays
sogar von Bösewichten mit Energiephotonen erdacht wurden. Es
war Silber, um auf Frank Amino-
Missionen in Brasilien zu enden
Globalismus durchsetzen  Die Pfarrei ist ein ungewohnter
Schock, der übersprungene Vermittler im
Berater der Herde, der Hilf ein
Kuckuck, komm schon, Komödie, scooty,
anova felishj, Gesundheit, und die
Schwestern IANA gab Lippenbekenntnisse ab, es in
Sahne Amanda macht Club, ist im
Shooter auf Laura Mitchell League  Hockey
-Superhop Kenneth Hagen verstärkt Orgel Kostas Die Betroffenen sind aus Neid des mitbegründeten McKernon, der in der
Beilage die Suppe füllt, eine Gitarre Norman Avenue
bei Monicas Gesundheitsinspektion
Bosman unehrliche Geldfront waren, um
als Episode II befruchtet von einem globalen
Casino para hist durchzusetzen  Also denke ich, dass
jeder diese Frage für sich selbst lösen muss,
aber für mich zum Beispiel waren
sie für uns als Familie so, wie wir darüber
denken, ist ein Nichtverständnis
, das zufällig unsere Aufgabe ist, also ist das
hilfreich, aber ich denke, jeder kann es versuchen
und ausgeben  etwas Zeit, um eine Sache zu verstehen
,
okay, eine der Fragen, die
sie besonders interessiert, und
sich damit vertraut zu machen und zu bekommen und darüber zu
lesen  hören und mehr darüber erfahren Ich
denke, das ist Verantwortung Nummer eins Ich
würde sagen, etwas Verständnis zu bekommen
und daraus zu lernen, und offensichtlich
versuchen Mütter, zuzuhören, zu lesen, vielleicht ein Fan zu gehen, vielleicht
weiter als die Zeitung, zu dem
Thema zu kommen, das Sie interessiert  Folgen und
lesen Sie Websites, versuchen Sie, Dokumente zu erhalten,
die aus den
Entwicklungsländern selbst stammen usw. Folgen Sie dem Thread.
Es gibt tatsächlich eine Menge Informationen
da draußen, um nicht für uns selbst zu werben, aber
unsere eigene Website ist ein guter Anfang,
wo sie Themen zu verschiedenen Themen enthält  Ich weiß, dass
es gute
Themen zu medizinischen Werten enthält, und es gibt Ihnen auch einen
Ort, an dem Sie mehr darüber lesen und
sich mit der Arbeit vertraut machen können,
die in Entwicklungsländern geleistet wird. Ich denke
, das ist jetzt möglich, und ein Ort, an dem
Sie diese auf unserer Website und dort unterbringen können  war eine
gute Website für den Anfang, die wir
mit dem Publikum teilen konnten.
Die andere Sache ist, dass es
für uns auch tatsächlich Geld
gibt, es klingt, es ist ein Pedes  Trian, aber ich
denke, wenn ich so verwende, wie du sagst, dass wir so
reich sind, denke ich, dass es eine Verantwortung ist, einen Teil davon zu geben,
und wenn du Zeit damit verbringst, zu
verstehen, hast du auch mehr Chancen
, es klug und auf eine Weise zu tun, von
der du weißt, dass es ist  Machen Sie einen Unterschied,
also geben Sie zum Beispiel Geld an
Organisationen, die Arbeit leisten,
die sich als effektiv erwiesen hat.
DiBiase Ich glaube an weniger effektiven
Altruismus  Ich bin Candice
Aviles  kann
Laura Pausini Inlandsanalytikerin Anna Hüften
zurück Velen Abrasax richtiges Essig
wirksames Währungskrankheitsdilemma oder
erstes Team würde ich s  Vielleicht ist es für
den einzelnen Spender, der in der
Schweiz sitzt und einen Job hat, also nicht
zu viel Zeit hat,
jemanden zu identifizieren, möglicherweise
schwierig für ihn, dorthin zu gehen und
diesen einen Ort zu finden, der wirklich
etwas Großartiges tut  Mit einer talentierten
Person könnte es möglich sein, aber es könnte
schwierig sein, also ist die Arbeit, die wir auf unserer Website leisten,
dass effektiver Altruismus Gutes
tut, dass
wir versuchen
, Organisationen zu identifizieren, die
Programme durchführen  die sich als effektiv erwiesen haben
und die es gut machen,
nicht allen dieser Organisationen wird
erlaubt, einige dieser
Organisationen sind ziemlich klein, viele lokal,
weil tatsächlich ihre lokalen Organisationen
die beste Arbeit mit dem
geringsten Aufwand leisten, also neigen sie dazu
von diesen Leuten ausgewählt werden,
und wenn Sie also eine begrenzte Zeit
und einen begrenzten Geldbetrag haben,
dann ist es irgendwie sinnvoll, damit
zu beginnen  und innerhalb dessen gibt es
die Möglichkeit, sich für die kleinste dieser Organisationen zu entscheiden, und dennoch wären Sie
einigermaßen zuversichtlich, dass sie
gute Arbeit leisten, und sich dann so
gut wie möglich mit ihrer Arbeit vertraut zu machen, von der Sie
wissen, dass sie Sie von einer Sache abbringen wird  zum
anderen vielleicht jemanden zu finden,
der versucht, dasselbe
von einem anderen Ort in den Wolken
nachzuahmen, sogar alle Menschen tun es mit Luton
Underwriter Scharnierspannweite eines
über T extrema verfügbaren Mesh-Panels. Ich würde
sogar herausstechen, dass ich es sein sollte  Ich meine, es
gibt keine Entschuldigung dafür, dass es nicht
ausgerottet wird. Ich denke, die Welt hat genug
Ressourcen, es ist wirklich ein winziger Geldbetrag, der
jeden
ziemlich anziehen wird. Ich meine, es gibt Orte wie
Somalia, wo wir nicht wissen, was wir dagegen tun sollen,
aber ich  Ich denke, an den meisten Orten der
Welt
leben die meisten armen Menschen in Staaten, die
viel tun, und ich denke, es gibt keinen Grund zu der
Annahme, dass wir es mit etwas mehr Ressourcen
nicht könnten, also denke ich, dass Loudness
Propylen Lewi ist  s Beaumont kommen unsere
Multi-Site können Sie extrema Ich würde
zumindest Informationen präsentiert, wie wir
heute Armut definieren ja ich meine, eine Hoffnung
in gewisser Weise ist, dass einmal die aktuelle
Zahl der Menschen leben und es
neunzig Dollar pro Tag gibt, was die aktuelle
Schwelle für ist  extreme Armut auf null geht,
dann ändern wir die Schwelle und wir
sagten, es sei wirklich nicht akzeptabel,
mit weniger als zweieinhalb
oder drei Dollar pro Tag zu leben, also denke ich, dass
es immer einen ärmsten Menschen auf
der Welt geben wird, und zwar den ersten  Person in der
Gesellschaft, und wir sollten uns
immer um diese Person kümmern, also wird
das Problem der Armut in gewisser Weise
bei uns sein, weil es immer eine
vierte Person geben wird, aber ich denke, dass es
möglich ist, dass die Menschen auf dieser Stelle
erheblich besser leben, und das sind nicht nur
wir  Wir sprechen nicht nur von Reibungen,
es ist wirklich so, dass sich in den letzten
30 Jahren viele Indikatoren
in der Welt verbessert haben, und Sie wissen, dass wir
über extreme Armut gesprochen haben, aber die
Anzahl der Kinder, die w  o die Zahl der Menschen, die
unter 5 Jahren gestorben sind,
wird seit 1990 durch 2 geteilt. Die Zahl der Menschen,
die an HIV sterben, wird seit etwa 2003 durch 2 geteilt.
Die Zahl der Kinder, die
Jungen und Mädchen zur Schule gehen, ist
bekannt  Grundschule ist es fast
jeder, also gab es
Fortschritte und es gibt noch viel zu
tun, aber es ist eine Geschichte, die
viele Lichtblicke aus dem Gleichgewicht bringt, und ich denke, wir
sollten aus diesen Erfolgen
lernen und versuchen, sie auszubauen
Erfolge sowohl mit mehreren Quellen als
auch mit einer besseren Nutzung dieser Ressourcen.
Phil-Elemente verlieren kein Fazenda-Problem.
m
berühmt in Zubrin ist Timmy Cartoon über Menschenschänder
der Frosch in den Fans der
Demokraten, die alle nach La Senora Zoo gestreckt werden,
kann nicht fair sein und durch dieses Zeichen und
Überweisungen als de Gelder
erwähnt, didi in M  Claren House Chicken Urin
eine unschöne Horntante erlaubt Martin die
skalierte Estação zu zweit in Amsterdams
Butakov in Betrieb Menschenökonomen
und zerreißen Tilde Schisma und
Zweiglungen Bujjis kommen Transocean Zubin auf
Überweisungen, die Rainfarn-Punkte des Lebens nicht
irgendein loses Furnier intime Emma Watson
düstere Mister sprudeln  und relevante
Entwicklung Verdächtige im Diagnosearm
haben nicht insbesondere Yara Marty Klein geschneit.
Ich denke, sie denken, dass Sie
nicht gesagt haben, was auch wichtig ist,
dass es so gut wie keine Beweise dafür gibt,
dass diese Leute die Länder gehört haben, in die
sie reisen  Tatsächlich
deuten alle Beweise darauf hin, dass sie auch
gut für die Länder sind, in die sie gehen,
weil viele dieser Länder dort
altern, dass
sie keine jungen Leute haben, die
junge Leute brauchen, also glaube ich nicht,
dass ich nur die Beweise lese
sorgfältig denke ich, dass dies
ziemlich auf der ganzen Linie
eine Win-Win-Situation zu sein scheint, abgesehen von der Tatsache, dass es
in der Welt ein gewisses Maß an
Paranoia gibt  Wenn Sie nicht anders aussehende Leute
kennen, die in meine
Nachbarschaft kommen werden, was ich als
etwas ansehe, über das wir verhandeln müssen, ist es
real, dass die Leute es spüren, aber ich denke,
die Wirtschaftlichkeit ist
ziemlich einfach, denke ich, zumindest die meisten Leute
Im Moment wird eine große Bewegung oder
Bevölkerung sowohl für
reiche als auch für arme Länder gut sein.
Viele buddhistische Länder wie die
Schweiz brauchen junge Menschen, und es ist eine
andere Sache, die er erwähnen sollte,
dass wir die Grenze weiter öffnen sollten
würde nicht sehen, dass bedeutete, dass wir nicht sehen würden,
wie ein riesiger Zustrom von Menschen plötzlich über
uns herfallen würde. Es gibt viele Gründe, warum
Menschen gerne bleiben, wo sie sind, und
so würden einige mehr Menschen kommen, aber nicht
in einem Ausmaß, dass es das Soziale verändern würde
auf radikale Weise, selbst zum
Beispiel dort, wo wir innerhalb von Ländern sehen,
wo die Menschen natürlich von einem
Ort zum anderen gehen können, wie sie wollen, wenn
man überhaupt möchte, dass mehr Menschen
umziehen  in die Städte, wo sie
viel mehr Geld verdienen würden, das sie
in Form von Überweisungen nach Hause schicken könnten, also
gibt es viele Dinge, die die
Menschen zurückziehen, also denke ich nicht, dass wir
uns Sorgen machen sollten, dass eine weitreichende Öffnung der Grenzen
Mutter weit führen würde  zu einem stillschweigenden
Massenstrom von Menschen, was es tun würde, wäre eine
leere Situation, die absolut
beschämend ist, so dass Sie Lager von
Menschen kennen, die
in einem Land wie Frankreich leben, und absolut schreckliche Bedingungen,
weil es nicht so viele
illegale Menschen geben würde, die in der Lage wären
kommen Sie legal nach Hause gehen Sie legal
wieder zurück und das ist wirklich
etwas, das
wir in Betracht ziehen würden, wenn
Duncan heute Abend hierher kommt, besonders
gesehen
Sogar ganze
Theater fühlten sich im Gespräch, sie fütterten,
darauf zu bestehen, ein bestimmtes Unternehmen in der Nähe zu sein.
Vielen Dank, vielen Dank. Ein
Manometer  Rehema dringt nicht von
Gibson über Arriba Abajo ein Mason Noah
Team schreit Craig net Casanova an der Gitarre
nicht auf Fosse auf Madonnas eine neue heiße
Namitha von Zion Voland der nächste Roman
Sorenstam Tisch Titan über einen örtlichen Zoo in
Boslov Huntsville kam im Oktober zu MIDI
Scotty  ANOVA Horton von verdammtem Delfin-
Investor Crema Randall CEO und ich
Maurish auf Santa Life Meter by sind
die Info-Spinnergie der Andhra-Website noch
/dt von Artikel sein Nile Rodgers Leben kann
in Mr. sein.  Kennedy hat jedes Tier mit seinem eigenen
Willen in der Freak-Ordnung, wir sind eine Familie,
heiße Feinde, veröffentlicht, um zu schrumpfen,
Physik, Newton und Motoren auf Tuck
[Musik]
Sie